une union de la santé voilà l'idée de la
commission européenne pour gérer
l'urgence de futures crises sanitaires
un outil de préparation et de
coordination qui doit voir le jour au
plus tôt en 2023 nous pourront exiger
légalement des états membres qu'ils
communiquent leurs données et
informations nous pourront surveiller
leurs capacités hospitalières leur unité
de soins intensifs et le personnel
soignant
nous serons aussi capable de déployer
des équipes d'experts dans les états
membres lorsqu'une crise sanitaire an
leur aide nécessaire
en attendant ce dispositif les 27 pays
de l'ue font face à la pandémie chacun à
leur manière la grèce déjà confinés a
décrété un couvre-feu nocturne à partir
de ce vendredi un confinement partiel
censé durer au minimum 30 jours pour la
hongrie où les rassemblements sont
désormais interdits chypre elle décidé
de confiner jusqu'à fin novembre ses
grandes villes portuaires où le nombre
de cas a explosé ces dernières semaines
au début ce n'était pas la même chose
parce que les pays européens avaient des
stratégies différentes
il ne disait pas clairement quelle
stratégie pourrait être la bonne et
maintenant tout le monde sait comment
gérer cela aspect le plus important est
vraiment de porter un masque si vous
quittez la maison
si vous voyez d'autres personnes eh bien
il faut porter un masque certifiés
cela réduit encore plus le risque la
france qui a durci son dispositif au
cours des dernières semaines est
aujourd'hui le pays européen le plus
touché reste à se montrer optimistes en
irlande en espagne en belgique ou encore
en république tchèque
de nouvelles mesures restrictives ont
permis de ralentir la transmission du
virus